hello and welcome to the shiki-san show
in this video we'll look at prime
editing why the hype so I'm not entirely
sure why I haven't done a video on gene
editing and CRISPR calf sign systems
already since I like to think of myself
a little bit of a Chris Forex birds I'm
joking it's not really quite the case
but I'm I have worked with and read a
lot of literature to deal with CRISPR
Castine so I was intrigued when a paper
came out last week which was all about
this new concept called prime editing
but before I jump stratum of prime
meditating let's first take a look at
Chris forecast 9 and some of its
limitations that kind of kick started
this publication so Chris Picasa 9 in
the context of genome editing involves a
protein called Castine that has
endonuclease activity such that it can
cut DNA and this can induce a
double-stranded break into the DNA and
then that's double trying to break these
be repairs and that is why editing can
occur in correct conditions and to get
to that target sites on DNA
it uses an RNA species referred to as a
guide RNA that's as kind of suggests
guides cast 9 to the target site on DNA
so I've actually kind of talks about
Castine and CRISPR system it's in a
previous blog that's all linked down
below but also check out this video I'm
given by Jennifer Doudna which I think
provides a really good introduction if
you're unfamiliar with this topic
probably better than myself but anyway
since I'll be useful for the rest of the
video I'll briefly introduce the
different domains of caffeine anyways
since the kind of fundamental for me to
explain in prime editing so here is cast
9 and as you can see there are two and
the nucleus domains one that cuts one
strand of DNA the other cuts the other
strand of DNA and so these different
domains can both be mutated such they
can't cut DNA or one could be mutated
such that you get a single strand break
in the DNA but in the wild-type
situation where you've got a double
strand break how does this hell deal
with this well there are two main types
of double strand break repair pathways
in a Cell an error-prone process called
non homology and joining or in terms of
precise genome editing there's homology
dependent repair mechanisms however
multiple publications including these
two papers here have effectively come to
the conclusion that double strand breaks
are not safe bottom line double strand
breaks a mutagenic you've shattered the
integrity of DNA and this inevitably
could result in tumor Genesis but more
specifically you can end up with
translocations of DNA you get activation
or p53 that can induce cell death or
cellular senescence as well as the fact
that we want precise genome edits and
double strand breaks can result in a
complex mix of products which
interesting but anyway since one of the
essential aims of genome editing is to
extend it to therapeutic applications we
want gene editing to be safe so that
means we have sponsor step away from
double strand breaks and tried to find
ways to edit DNA with either single
strand breaks or with no breaks at all
the problem is using either single
stranded breaks or no breaks at the
moment for editing is very inefficient
so how to improve this efficiency so
numerous attempts have already been made
using either single or double mutants of
the under nucleus domains so to enable
precise genome editing from only single
stranded breaks a donor DNA with the
targeted changes is required in addition
to the Cassadine complex and so to
improved efficiency different approaches
have been taken and mostly these involve
fusing this cast line so-called nikkei's
to different protein domains that can
try and increase the editing efficiency
the idea is that these different domains
that have been fused can open up DNA or
make him more accessible to this donor
DNA to encourage incorporation of the
targeted changes into the target DNA
sites the methods for editing with no
breaks most frequently
disgust is based editing and that uses a
so-called dead cast line because it
can't cut either strand of DNA and the
cast line is infused two different
deaminase domains however this approach
is so far limited and what changes it
can actually do so it converts cytosine
thymine guanine adenine adenine guanine
as well as thymine to cytosine but other
changes currently can't be used for your
based editing so this approach is good
because it's safer but it's very much
limited and what it can do it is also
prone to off target changes as is single
strand break and double strand breaks as
well so the kind of Idol golden approach
for precise genome editing is to have a
technique that uses either single strand
breaks or no breaks but still enables at
an efficient rate substitutions
deletions or insertions of nucleotides
so that the editing technique is very
fast at all and can be used to treat
multiple different types of genetic
diseases so bring in prime editing can
it overcome these challenges so the
authors of the paper have described
prime editing as a search and replace
genome editing technique and so as we'll
see prime editing doesn't need during
the DNA doesn't use double strand breaks
and so it doesn't actually use the while
typecast 9 and because of these changes
it enables precise editing with lower
off-target effects so how do they
achieve this well welcome to the
first-ever Sheehy's understanding well
I'll try and explain just this so in the
canonical cast 9 editing system we have
our cast line protein and we have a
guide RNA and we have it recognizing our
target DNA sites where induces a double
strand break so this single guide RNA
that I've course in this diagram here is
actually a combination of two RNA
components a tracer RNA that binds
Castine it kind of acts as a template
for its bones and the crisp RNA which is
the part of the RNA that actually
recognizes the target DNA sites and
since DNA is double-stranded and the
guide RNA is only going to recognize one
strands the strands that it does
recognize and bind to is referred to as
the target strands and the opposite
strands is therefore referred to as it
gets the third non-target strands
and so the last bit of lingo that you
kind of needs to get to grips with is
the so called Pam or the proto space are
adjacent Retief and so this is just
three nucleotides and the case of cast
nine my teeth in DNA that cast nine
needs to recognize such that it can
actually cut the DNA so the palm is
integral to the cutting of the DNA
strand so yeah it can get quite
complicated if you are new to this
concepts and so as I have already
mentioned for precise genome editing
using a canonical cast nine the cell
also needs to be provided with a donor
DNA template that contains the desired
gene edits so as you will see prime
editing achieves genome editing without
using this donor DNA and that's
desirable because it's just one less
component to have to add to the cell but
without the donor DNA how can this be
done and without using the base editing
approach that we know is already a
little bit limited what about the guide
RNA the team rationalised and so they
noticed that you can obviously extend
from the three prime end of the single
guide RNA and this could be extended
even further such that the three prime
end could eventually come back and I
knew further down the target DNA sites
and then it could contain the targeted
changes but so how would they be
integrated so a lot of research has
evidently gone into this field and one
paper seems to suggest that the pam
distal non target strand is excluded
from the coastline complex so out of the
four strands where you have the
double-stranded break this non target
pam distal strands but if math fool
seems to be released in which case this
strand is therefore accessible to
different enzymes so what happens if you
had cast I infused or a fast
transcriptase a protein that uses RNA as
a template to add DNA nucleotides to
three prime ends of DNA Oh exciting and
combining that with the fact that we
don't want
double-stranded breaks we only want to
work with
trailer brakes to get this non-target
thumb distal strand released the HK 40 a
cast nine which only cuts the non target
Stratton's needs to be used so if I
complete the picture with the extended
single guide RNA as well we have the
premise of prime editing so I'm now
showing the figure from the publication
because honestly it's a little bit
prettier and what accurate than my own
drawing so what you can see is you can
see the what they cool as the peg RNA
which is the prime editor it's grade RNA
and so you can see the primary set guide
RNA in the complex with this cast line
the 80-48 mutation used to they were
first transcriptase and you can see it
interact with the target DNA sites and
you can see that they've labeled onto
the peg on a a primer binding sites
which is the complementary between the
RNA and the target DNA sites and they
call it the primer binding site because
it Prime's the end of the DNA site for
action by their first transcriptase
which will then copy the desired edits
from the template into the DNA and so
once the authors established that this
system works they decided that they
wanted to improve it to improve
efficiency so they then go on to explain
what they now call prime editor - which
is where they've improved the efficiency
or the reverse transcriptase and so by
having five different mutations they
were able to increase the thermal
stability of the enzyme the processivity
the DNA to RNA affinity and ultimate
activate the RNase H activity of the
Refresh transcriptase which could
effectively degrade RNA which is kind of
not what you want when you want to use
RNA as a template for teen extension so
with these changes they were they were
able to you further improve the
efficiency which is one of the aims of
gene editing but there's a problem and
this problem is hindering increasing the
efficiency further and that's once
you've extended the DNA with your
targeted changes
you've now got a bit of a battle between
your DNA with the wanted changes and the
original DNA and it's like a fight as to
which one's gonna gave an eel back down
to the double DNA strand and then
there's another problem let's say that
are targeted edits were integrated but
now you've got a mismatch between the
Edit South but integrated and the
previous of the strands of the DNA you
have a mismatch and see which strands is
going to be chosen during DNA
replication
now once the first problem is pretty
much a kind of 50/50 odds on kind of
lock system the second problem can
actually be optimized and saying one way
to kind of bias the cell to keep the
targeted changes is to Nick the other
strands that wasn't edited and say if
that strands Nick's it's effectively
damaged and so you during DNA
replication is more likely that the
intact strand is going to be kept
because that strand is in tax it's more
likely to be correct so you can kind of
trick the cell into keeping the strands
but if your targeted changes obviously
this isn't a hundred percent but it does
increase the odds the problem now is
that potentially you could get staggered
double strand breaks and also there's
now more components to add the cells for
this to work but it's all about the
balance between efficiency and safety
and how that's gonna be dealt with is
yourself a question and facade
optimization so I feel like I did kind
of waster it out so as a brief summary
to what prime editing is there are three
kind of key components that are
essential you need to have target DNA
peg RNA spacer complementarity
so that the cast iron can bind the
targeted DNA site you then need to have
this primer binding sites to be
complementary to the DNA as well and so
that's remember it's only the extension
of the RNA and so that's the bit that
Prime's the refresh transcriptase and
the last thing you need to have target
DNA i'm complementarity with the reverse
transcriptase product so that you get
the flat presentation which is this
battle that I was talking about so you
probably meditating has caused a lot of
hype to cut it because it is really
exciting that this
is a new facet all relatively safe and
efficient application for gene editing
but it's not 100% safe and so there are
some other issues that still need to be
resolved and this tweet kind of goes
through lots of different points that
I'll briefly summarize here for the
system to work it has to be done in
cells that actually have the capacity to
deal with this flat prepare there's also
the potential that the reverse
transcriptase could just keep going and
go further into the peg RNA itself and
you could end up with the peg on e being
inserted the sequence being inserted
into the genome as well which is not
ideal and there's the facts as I
mentioned about essentially getting
double strand breaks as a consequence of
having the tuner khazars and then
there's also the facts of how are you
going to be able to translate this
worked in fever work it's at the moment
it's just been done in cell line stats
are kind of already relatively easy to
edit CRISPR Castine what about other
cell types that they haven't tested what
about the delivery of the system how is
that gonna happen and the other thing
that Jonathan mentions is the issue of
the paper that they mentioned that with
prime editing in theory they can now
tackle nearly 90% of the more than
75,000 disease associated DNA Ferren
variants but I mean if there's a
difference between saying yes short
prime editing's pretty fast at all but
there are many other factors that go
into being able to edit DNA sites and I
think it's wrong to advertise that
obviously there's a potential chance but
is it shouldn't be falsely advertised or
over hyped but it's definitely up there
has been pretty cool gets chi-chi's
approval it's pretty awesome so be
interesting to see how this technology
is developed further so I think it's a
really exciting time to see where you
know gene editing takes us so while
trying to put down all the different
links and stuff that I've mentioned in
this video down below so do check it out
and don't yeah just don't take my word
for it um but yeah it's pretty cool and
so hopefully you've gained something
from this video so thank you listening